what is happening reject nation it's
greg alba kobayashi oh why so wala was
away in colorado the defenders appeared
on netflix meaning i can finally wear a
defender shirt while talking about an
episode of the defenders i'm gonna be
covering episode 1 and 2 today i've seen
it multiple times on social media and
here on youtube that if you combine
what's coming out in 2017 movies and TV
shows that the defenders is what i've
been anticipating the absolute most
because i'm watchin the show while in
between doing other youtube videos and
doing stuff for patron and a bunch of
other things too i figured i'd just
update you guys on my experience of
watching the show instead of just doing
a direct breakdown and review of every
single episode i mean under the videos
title review because essentially that's
what it will be but it's not what i mean
as i govern the episode so far I've only
watched two episodes and I got to tell
you guys man
a little letdown I feel like
specifically with daredevil Jessica
Jones and Luke Cage I was hooked within
the first couple episodes of those shows
I would have a hard time turning off the
TV and just going to sleep I just had to
binge watch it I mean this time around
they're combining all these characters
and yet as the show was progressing but
two hours worth of television I found
myself less invested I put out a tweet
asking people what episodes of the
defenders have moments that are worth
doing reactions to and there's only
about three or four episodes that people
said are worth doing it for and a lot of
people actually came back with a
response that the first few episodes are
kind of boring I just didn't believe
that they would be I really didn't and
then I watched it and I was like oh it
kind of is a little dull however as a
big however however knowing the binging
format that Netflix the boasts or TV
shows for I can tell that right now only
a couple episodes in that it's just
doing a lot of setting up a lot of
building up or when the defenders
officially assemble defenders assemble
we can say that is marvel now knowing
the way YouTube's retention rate works
most people have probably already
clicked off the video by now because I'm
just not that interesting but if you're
still here allow me to go to some
positives that I felt there are definite
aspects to this setup that I appreciate
the first episode none of the main four
heroes come together it really is not
rushing the team-up it's establishing
Iron Fist solo mission you know trying
to take down the hand Luke Cage getting
out and readjusting to his new life as
harlem's
Matt Murdock is trying not to be
Daredevil and Jessica Jones is back to
being alcoholic who takes on a private
eye case out of guilt in curiosity these
steps are all fine and quite necessary
for where we last left these characters
and it's building up this mystery plot
point of Sigourney Weaver's character
Alexandra whose introduction reminded me
a bit of Wilson Fisk's because she's the
big baddie of the show yet in her
introduction we find out she's dying and
she's in this very vulnerable state her
first scene she's this incredibly
vulnerable similar to how when we first
meet Wilson Fisk he's in a very
vulnerable state
it makes me feels like so this moment
when we first meet Alexander I found
interesting because she's immediately
humanized his every scene following her
after the moment with the doctor she's
pretty much what we expected her to be
she's really tough she's really business
savvy she controls the room she's in
she's intimidating and her dynamics with
madam chair I find very intriguing as
well because Madam's show it's like the
first time we're seeing she's definitely
intimidated by this
Alexandra character and I'm still not
entirely sure who Alexandra is or what
she's even capable of completely doing
and the storylines from where the main
defenders characters are at what they're
currently doing all that does make sense
and I feel like later on in the show the
first couple episodes will be even more
rewarding like after seeing the entirety
of the series so right now the tonal
shifts just don't quite work for me
because each one of these characters
solo shows have a very specific look and
feel to them daredevil is the gritty
vigilantes story that has a red color
tint Luke Cage is the black exploitation
heroic tale with like a yellow color
tint to it Jessica Jones is to film the
war tale with like a blue and then you
got iron fist which is just kind of
bland with a blue tint to it and you
know about a warrior trying to figure
himself what he really has to do who he
has to be you know you know artifice so
I feel like on paper cutting back and
forth between these four stories within
the first couple episodes that sounds
really cool on paper because each time
we cut to these characters it's like
their solo show is continuing so if
we're a set up on paper and I keep
saying that that sounds great but in
terms of watching a series the tonal
balance is kind of frustrating cuz it
just doesn't feel balanced well each one
of these characters has a specific show
that have very specific vibes so
whenever they do these like weird trance
to these characters I find myself as a
viewer having to readjust my viewing
experience have you guys ever seen cloud
Alice I sort to feel like I'm having a
similar experience what Alice is this
multi-story film where they cut back and
forth between several stories and that
format can work for example a film like
crash cuts around between several
storylines but it's not a weird or
uneven viewing experience because the
storylines and the way their shot and
tonally they're they're similar enough
where does Claude Atlas was this movie
where they cut around to several
different stories that all feel and look
like completely different movies and
that's sort of how I feel about the
defenders right now I mean the good
thing about the defenders is that
they're all stories about being heroes
so it won't be hard to adjust when they
all finally come together but the tone
and vibe maybe each of their stories is
so different it's like when they finally
cut to Matt Murdock I have to readjust
and then it takes me a bit of time to
get into the feel and the tone and the
story and that Murdock then after I'm
into it they cut to a different
character than I'm doing the whole
readjusting experience all over again
and this was a consistent issue I was
finding it's essentially the main reason
why I'm having a hard time just feeling
the show allow myself to just be fully
engrossed and more importantly being
emotionally hooked by the experience but
most part it's all interesting I've just
thought my heart's not fully in it
because I feel like I'm watching a show
where the writers room is struggling to
find a balance between for other shows I
guess what I would have liked for this
show to do is find a unique look and
tone for the defenders series that's who
made the first Avengers movie work so
what Joss Whedon was able to find a tone
and look that is unique specifically for
the crossover movie here it's just
cutting back and forth between different
shows instead of finding a look and tone
for this specific crossover series and
also I'm finding the build-up and the
personal drama to be a little stretched
out I mean for a season that's only
eight episodes long I could use buildup
for sure but not so much stretching [ __ ]
out daredevil is easily my favorite
character out of the four defenders and
I totally get and that feeling guilty is
one of the things that Matt Murdock does
is the Catholic boy that he is so my
issue with the story here is we all know
he's gonna be daredevil again there's no
need to build it up so much watching him
have tension with foggy and Karen
is just kind of repetitive to me I mean
I still love Charlie Cox's performance
and I still love seeing foggy and Ken
but after episode one it sort of starts
to feel like you pick this up a little
bit already and then there's the mystery
plot of what jessica jones is
investigating and what Luke Cage is
investigating and I feel the potential
the plot and I feel that it's building
up to the four of them coming together
that all their plots are obviously gonna
coincide but I also feel like we're
watching a plot without personal
investment in the main plot Jessica
Jones season one worked so well because
the plot of her mission is she's setting
out to find kill Griff men who raped and
used her Luke Cage has a personal
vendetta against cottonmouth and a
personal relationship with Harlem and
their stories in the defenders have a
mystery element yes but not a personal
element to them if that makes sense and
Danny ran he's essentially doing the
same [ __ ] he did in iron fist and well I
think Finn Jones thus far is doing a
decent job I would say it's probably
doing a better job than you didn't an
iron fist he's still easily the most
boring part of the defenders yeah
Alexandra storyline is sort of
intriguing right now if anything I
wanted them to do what they do at kill
Graham and Wilson Fisk where you build
her up and then we get to see who she is
and then we get to see what she's really
doing right now the show is showing me
what she's doing but I don't really know
what the hell she's doing it's just kind
of confusing so it just feels like a lot
of questions with not a strong feeling
of personal investment a lot of build-up
for a show that I don't think needs this
much build-up there's some great
character moments there's some good
action moments the fight between Luke
Cage Danny Rand was pretty cool Matt
Murdock finding those people in the
streets was kind of cool too and overall
I still really liked the performances of
pretty much everyone involved especially
Matt Murdock Jessica Jones and Luke Cage
but I guess because of the tonal shifts
that keep happening and the lack of
personal investment in the main plot
that it's building towards and let me
clarify I don't think it's 100% void of
personal investment that's why there's
all this build-up and personal life
drama these characters are having that's
where all like the personal elements
come into play I just think well me the
first three shows work so well was the
personal drama combined with the main
plot having personal stakes as well so
that way everything feels personal and
emotional and I can see the plot getting
more personal for Matt Murdock because
Elektra is working for Alexandra right
she looks like she's under some kind of
mind control so I could see that when
Matt Murdock gets involved it's gonna
get more personal because a lecture is
involved and the confessional scene he
had was you know very big set up for all
that to happen is currently I know I'm
only on the first two episodes I feel
these characters have personal drama but
not enough dramatic investment in the
main plot that will cause these four to
come together like I said at the
beginning of this spiel I know this is
all building up this is all setting up
so by the time the show kicks into gear
I'm sure it'll all be worth it in the
end and it'll probably make the first
two episodes even better that's where I
stand right now I'm currently disabling
comments for just a little while after
Game of Thrones is done and after I'm
caught up on the defenders because I've
seen videos that are not defenders
linked and not Game of Thrones linked
but people are still putting spoilers in
there it pisses me off so I'm just
current Lee disabling comments right now
if you have any video requests hit us up
on Facebook or on Twitter that's usually
work better anyway yeah I'm still
looking forward to finishing the show
just a little letdown that the first
couple hours of the show will be kind of
dull I hear episode 3 starts really
kicking things in a much faster pace and
so I'm looking forward to it you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bow follow me at the Greg
albon insta and twit tests and check out
our patreon for exclusive perks and
goodies over there have another fun yeah